Well,
Goldman recognize some of the problems
early on.
I can't say that you understood all that
was coming,
but certainly they repor recky dies the
subprime mortgage crisis early in 2007
long before,
uh,
the crunch 18 months before the big
crunch hit in the fall 2008.
So he had a lot of firms like ups,
a Swiss from continuing to invest
heavily in subprime mortgages and losing
tens of billions more.
I think Goldman lost about 70 million in
that crisis.
But then in August of 2007,
a very significant event took place that
I talk about in my book seven lessons.
And that's that uh,
three of the quantitative quantitative
funds,
Goldman has went way down 30 to 40% as
did all quant funds that day.
And it was,
this volatility was so extreme that the
management saw that there's something
odd going on in the markets and our
models don't predict what's going on.
And as a result,
they pulled back and said,
we're going to start accumulating cash.
You could say hardy cash accumulating
cash.
And so they spent a full year
accumulating a lot of cash.
So they came into the crisis in
September,
2008 with over $120 billion in cash.
If Layman had had another 20 billion,
they probably would have been saved,
but they didn't take those kind of
moves.
And so yes,
there was a run on cash.
Yes,
there's liquidity crunch,
but they were willing to,
to uh,
they,
they had the capacity to stand in to
that.
And I think that's a good lesson for all
of us.
One of the things I talked about in my
book,
get ready for the long haul because if
you think things are bad today,
they're going to get worse,
not better.
And so you need to be ready for a long
haul problem and have the cash reserves
to pull you through it.
No,
I don't.
I think a,
a firm like Goldman,
it's human capital that matters and
that's why you have to be so sensitive.
The board spends an enormous amount of
time on the human capital getting to
know the people at all levels.
Who are the,
who are the rising stars,
who are the people coming up in the
system?
Uh,
I got a surprise as did the rest of the
board.
When Hank Paulson change his mind
decided,
said,
except president bushes offered to
become secretary of the treasury.
That was may of 2006 and thank goodness
we not only knew Lloyd,
but we knew all the other top people.
And we can make considered decisions not
just about the CEO,
but who the other structure where a Gary
Cohen or Jon winkelried,
he could step up and other people could
take on greater responsibility and
awaken hanks departure.
Had we not known these people,
we couldn't have done that.
Now we're asking,
you know,
who's going to be the next CFO?
Is gonna be the next chief personnel
officer?
It could be the next general counsel who
are all these people.
And so we have dinner with these people.
We get to see him live and in action.
They present to the board.
Very good system.
It could board doesn't do that.
You're in trouble.
But it is human capital.
It's not a tech.
You can,
you do the technology,
but everyone does the technology.
That's nothing unique about that.
The only thing unique is the human gap.
I like the word resilient because there
were going to have with the timeframe
compressed for technology change,
uh,
and operating in global markets,
they're going to be more crises.
This is hardly the last.
And so I think firms need to be
resilient and the system needs to be
resilient and waiting for secretary
geithner and Ben Bernanki to put in
some,
uh,
frankly some,
some complete policies including the
regulations and ensure the systems
resilience.
They keep talking about it.
Here we are a year later,
nothing has been done unlike Sarbanes
Oxley,
which done in 31 days.
But I think firms need to have that
resilience.
One of them has ever,
resilience is never to get so much
leverage and drive your firms so hard
that you don't have the cash to fall
back on when you hit a crisis.
That's why General Motors went bankrupt.
And that's why Ford,
uh,
came through the crisis because they'd
taken out $24 billion in loans and,
uh,
that allow,
has allowed for it to come through.
That's very strong.
Where as GM and Chrysler had to get
bailed out by the government.